okay um it was not just
rallies that donald trump did this
weekend he was also interviewed by fox
news's mark levin
now if you don't know who mark levin is
he's
almost like a protege of sean hannity if
you can imagine
as propagandistic and perverse
and depraved as sean hannity is
mark levin is a guy that hannity for
years
referred to as the great one the
interview
was arguably as disconnected from
reality
as any interview donald trump has
previously done after donald trump went
on a completely
absurd rant about water mark levin tells
him you know what i like about you
you're not an ideologue irony is dead
it's dead take a look you would have so
much water in california
you'd be able all those fields that are
open i mean i've never seen that you
drive it down the highway and
everything's
like really terrible looking and then
you have this gorgeous patch of
green that's the only area they have the
water they are loud like this tiny
amount of water
that whole thing could be farmland but
they send the water out into the pacific
ocean
you know it's a long story but there are
many many stories like that
the stupidity of it all cause i listen
to you
in these different areas
you're not an idiot it's common sense
can you imagine seeing donald trump
attack people on the left
who aren't even in charge for everything
from not raking forests
to not giving trump enough water
pressure to flush his toilets why trump
needs to flush 10 to 15 times i don't
know
and then saying you know what i like
about you is you're not
ideological i have no idea
how this next comment makes sense donald
trump seemingly talking about chicago
and then jumps right into afghanistan
it's almost like
the the it is a verbal inkblot i think
is the right term
look at chicago where 58 people were
shot
this isn't like where there was a
fighter this is was shot
right shot and they now the reports are
58 people were shot this weekend in
chicago 10 died okay let's get on to the
weather how's the weather
they've gotten almost used to it 58
people
so we're pulling out of afghanistan as
you know we're very close to getting out
does anybody see the connection media
coverage of 58 people
shot in chicago is related to pulling
out of afghanistan is this adult adhd
is it cognitive decline is it ignorance
is it panic
and then trump continuing his brutal
assault on water on and on and on
now going on about a massive valve and
mark levin just sits there
nodding like this makes sense trump also
talking about
a very small fish
and yet they have they have no water and
they're going to ration
for everybody and all they have to do is
let the water come down you know what
they do with the water
they send it out into the pacific ocean
they have this massive valve
up north and as the water comes
pouring down from the snow and all
beautiful
nice clean water they send it out
because there's a tiny little fish that
they're trying to save that's doing very
poorly by the way i think it's a smelt
tiny little fish doing very poorly doing
much worse now without the water i mean
i don't know you know
you think you do better with the water
but they have this massive
valve and they turn this massive takes a
whole day to turn it
and all that water comes and it comes
pouring and you know where it goes into
the pacific
but kevin mccarthy sees me says do you
think you could work on the water we
can't get any water from the farm
the rantings of a madman truly then
trump again
raising the topic of explosive trees so
let's just look i just left as you know
california i met with the governor
and he and and honestly he's been very
nice
with the words and that's good but i
said we gotta you gotta manage this
it's a management thing he said no it's
global warming
but i said when the leaves build up and
you have a floor of leaves and the trees
fall down and you don't remove them
because the environmentalists don't want
you to touch the tree
within 18 months that tree gets to be
like a matchstick it gets to be
unbelievably flammable and i meet with
foreign leaders
of countries and they have an expression
sir we are a forest nation but they say
we have trees that are far more
explosive than the trees in california
do you think that after the interview is
over
mark levin says what the hell happened
what what on earth was donald trump
talking about because mark levin
is a horrible ideologue but he's not an
idiot
in the way that donald trump is does
mark levin get it do you think
at one point the topic of trump's former
national security adviser john bolton
came up
and trump said if it were up to bolton
we'd be in world war 5 right now
john bolton was a very stupid person
if i listened to john bolton we'd be in
world war 5 right now
i guess in this imaginary nightmare
trump would be responsible for world
wars 3 and 4
but bolton would have gotten us into
world war 5. and then mark levin just
nodding nodding nodding as if this makes
sense
and then speaking of people trump used
to work with trump again
referenced people being fired like dogs
i disagree with mattis very much
he was fired by president obama he was
fired
like a dog he was fired does donald
trump know what dogs are
we know trump doesn't relate to his
children normally my guess is trump
wouldn't relate to dogs normally either
what is fired like a dog even mean and
then
last one trump the victim here is poor
trump
whining to mark levin like mark levin is
his mommy
about how everybody treats him so
unfairly
uh the washington post is is a disaster
you can't get a good story it's
disgusting
and then you go to abc nbc probably is
the worst of all comcast i call it
comcast
not comcast it's a con job because they
always try and protect their name like
how
legitimate they are nbc is horrible cbs
is a disaster and then you go into the
the real beauty is that
msdnc as we call it and
of course cnn but at least cnn you know
where they're coming from you know
they're stone cold dishonest
at least you know that so it's a um
it's a sad thing i mean it's a very sad
thing i fortunately local press is
extremely good i get
great local whenever i stop for a speech
i do one or two local reporters
these are the greatest stories it's like
unbelievable they
cover it so good actually they're
they're almost
uh more enthusiastic than i am and
so we have that we have some
honest media a fox is is good but fox is
not what it was i'd be i'll be
very honest with you i don't know they
become politically correct you know they
think it's wonderful they have more
democrats on than they have
practically than they have republicans
i'm complaining about it all the time
you know
with all of that being said we're doing
much better than we did four years ago
tough being a billionaire president of
the united states right you're just it's
just
everybody treats you so poorly really a
tough situation
for donald trump these interviews are of
real bona fide sociological
value propaganda value it's not
journalism
but hugely relevant for propaganda
studies